und jetzt live zuschauer noch ein
hinweis in eigener sache die heute show
hat in ihrer letzten ausgabe einen rede
ausschnitt von dieter amann gezeigt
seines zeichens mitarbeiter der afd
baden württemberg wir hatten diesen rede
ausschnitt und zwar so wie er bei uns
gezeigt wurde aus dem mittagsmagazin
mitgeschnitten und niemandem aus unserer
redaktion ist auch nur der verdacht
gekommen
man könnte oder einer sprachstörung
leiden wie wir inzwischen wissen gab es
seine komplette rede in einem
mehrstündigen internet video und darin
erklärt der einleiten selber dass er
unter einer solchen sprachstörung leidet
auch das war uns leider nicht bekannt
wenn herr amann also den eindruck hatte
wir hätten uns über ihn lustig gemacht
wegen einer sprachstörung und nicht
wegen des furchtbaren inhalt seiner
ausführungen tut uns das tatsächlich
sehr leid
und diese entschuldigung gilt
ausdrücklich den menschen die da man das
als antwort auf den anderen kids zu
haben der uns erreicht hat mit dem tenor
wie kann man sich denn bitte bei der afg
entschuldigen habe ich gar nicht meine
damen und herren
nur so viel an die adresse der afg und
ihrer wütenden fans die uns zahlreich
geschrieben haben da er in der causa man
offenbar die politische korrektheit nun
doch wieder zurück geholt habt vom
müllhaufen der geschichte was toll ist
jetzt in keinem fall nachlassen
setzt euch bitte auch in zukunft weiter
ein für schwächere oder für
diskriminierte minderheiten vielleicht
sogar mal für welche und jetzt bin ich
wirklich total die nicht in deutschland
geboren wurden
auch in euch schlummer garantiert ein
gutmensch lasst ihn einfach raus und das
war die heute schon jetzt kommen
[Applaus]